all right this is super interesting and
it's really just a pleasure to watch
one of the most prominent people who
plans to formally object
sir i object to the counting of the
electoral votes tomorrow
is republican senator josh hawley
because josh hawley was
i guess because he was the first senator
to announce he would object
he's received more attention than some
other senators who jumped on the
bandwagon after the fact
and josh hawley went on fox news
yesterday good for him
and brett bayer actually pushed back on
the nonsense that josh hawley was
touting and josh hawley
became visibly uncomfortable he had that
look on his face that tucker carlson is
known for
where it's sort of like a dog hearing
your voice out of the answering machine
and kind of like a confusion um and when
bret bayer starts pushing back on josh
hawley josh hawley gets that look
here is bret bayer starting with what
exactly is the point of you objecting
tomorrow or you know wednesday uh what
what do you what is the goal of that
take a listen
so the supreme court didn't take up that
that case either they did not take up
the quick case
the supreme court we've seen courts
across the country
deal not only with not the standing of
different cases but
also the evidence and some of them
trump's trump
judges i just want to pin you down on on
what you're trying to do
you know are you trying to say that as
of january 20th
that president trump will be president
well that that depends on what happens
on wednesday i mean this is why we have
the debate
no it doesn't i mean the states by the
constitution
say they certify the election they did
certify it
by the constitution congress doesn't
have the right to overturn the
certification
at least as most experts read it so
brett bayer is completely correct
tomorrow's electoral vote count is
ceremonial mike pence's role
is perfunctory the states have already
certified their
electoral votes that's the legally
binding piece state certification
tomorrow is really ceremonial
and this is where josh hawley starts to
get a sour puss
look on his face like he bit into a
lemon and to stop to start to tell some
lies
well congress is is directed under the
12th amendment to
count the electoral votes there's a
statute that dates back to the 19 to the
1800s rather 19th century
that says that there is a right to
object there's a right to be heard and
there's also a certification right
that's from 1876 senator and it's
it's the the tilden hayes race in which
there were three states that did not
certify their their electors
so congress was left to come up with
this system this commission
that eventually got to a negotiated
grand bargain but
now all of the states have certified
their elections
as of december 14th so it doesn't by
constitutional ways
open a door to congress to overturn that
does it when brett bayer
knows the example that holly is
referring to
holly realizes oh no this is not going
to go that well
and brett bayer is completely correct
what josh hawley is referring to
is a mechanism that's really in place
for when some states have not
certified the electoral vote that's not
the case this year
every state on uh what december 14th
can you believe it's been a month since
then it feels like days on december 14th
every state certified the electoral vote
and then listen to josh hawley's answer
well no i'm talking about the statute
brett there's a statute that says that
governs what congress does
on january the 6th and it says that we
have a vote of certification and that we
have to we have the opportunity to
debate the results to certify the
results we count them and then we
certify
and my point is this is my only
opportunity
during this process to raise an
objection and to be heard i don't have
standing to file lawsuits
i'm not a prosecutor anymore i used to
be but i'm not anymore i can't
investigate
claims of voter fraud on my own but i do
have a responsibility
in this joint session of congress to
either say i've got no problem with it
or i do have a problem with it and my
constituents expect don't you have a
responsibility to your constituents
don't you have a responsibility to tell
them that it's not going to be
president trump as of january 21st as
well
well brett so there josh hawley kind of
admits the truth
which is this is all i can do and that's
what this is all about
what is there that anyone can do given
that joe biden won
and all they can do is virtue signal to
donald trump
that they are trying that they are
trying so holly has definitely
uh he he seemed to be expecting more of
a fawning softball interview from bret
baer
much of the fox news audience is furious
with bret baer for pointing out that
josh hawley
is lying to them after all you would
think that an audience would want to
know
if an elected official is lying to them
but no
the fox audience is mad that brett bayer
exposed josh hawley's lies but
holly's just squirming and it's
fantastic
and it will all be over very soon i'm
still receiving
and we even got some paid super chats
during yesterday's trump rally
live stream i'm still getting messages
from people saying
totally seriously david don't you
realize that by thursday
trump will be the official winner and
biden is going to be in handcuffs
well listen i don't even have to argue
we're down to the last 48 hours
let's wait and see and we will see very
soon let me know what you expect
tomorrow in washington dc
let me know via twitter where you can
find me at deepakman
if one of your goals for the new year is
to cut back on carbs and sugar
check out one of our sponsors monk pack
monk pack keto granola bars fill you up
and taste like your favorite sweet
snacks
but they just have one gram of sugar
just two grams of net carbs at only 140
calories they have
a soft chewy texture and they come in
delicious flavors like coconut cocoa
chip
peanut butter and maple pecan
or pecan or pecan it's all of the above
actually
they're perfect for a quick breakfast a
snack between zoom calls
or a late night treat not only are they
keto friendly they're gluten free
grain-free plant-based no soy trans fats
or sugar alcohols no artificial colors
and monk pack is so confident in their
keto snacks
that they back them with a hundred
percent money back guarantee
try it for yourself and you'll see how
delicious
these are you'll get twenty percent off
when you go to monkpack.com and use
coupon code
pacman the link is underneath this video